boa noite
o professor falou meu nome é ana alice é
eu sou professora chico 4 cantava
naquela música assim o meu pai era
paulista meu governo a boca no meu caso
é assim assim o meu pai professora minha
mãe também as minhas irmãs estão na sala
os meus tios também enfim eu estou
cercada de educação e educação é a minha
paixão é o que eu faço por uma escolha
profissional e o que eu faço
acreditando que eu sou capaz de mudar o
mundo
eu trabalho numa escola que vai fazer 25
anos e essa escola conheci ou ela não
começou com os pequenininhos
ela começou com crianças mais velhas e
há algum tempo mas decidimos dar início
à educação infantil
a nossa pesquisa em cima de educação
infantil visava encontrar uma educação
infantil diferente que saísse daquele
modelo que acredito que a maioria de nós
teve como modelo de educação e aí
pesquisando a nossa equipe foi estudando
e nós chegamos à cidade italiana de
regime na ilha regime ilha fica ao norte
da itália e é uma cidade que mudou se
transformou a partir do final da segunda
guerra mundial era uma cidade totalmente
destruída ea partir da manifestação das
mulheres da necessidade feminina de
encontrar um espaço que fosse capaz de
acolher as crianças foram construídas
novas escolas é essa história veio
acontecendo ao longo dos anos mas em
uma revista famosa norte americana deu
destaque a essas escolas dizendo que
eram as melhores escolas de educação
infantil no mundo e isso foi tomando uma
proporção muito grande com diversas
publicações que chegaram até o brasil
que a gente teve contato
essa inspiração regiana ela tem por
princípio fundamental o protagonismo
infantil
a gente entende que a criança ela é
protagonista ela é um ator dos
principais atores dentro da sociedade
bom eu falar um pouquinho disso esse é o
aris malagutti se ele foi o responsável
um dos teóricos que deu início a essa
nova abordagem educacional
essa abordagem que têm diferentes
aspectos dos quais eu vou falar e que
consegue fazer com que a criança
realmente tenha destaque
essa minha mariana
a mariana estudou com a gente desde os 3
anos hoje ela tem sete anos e já foi
alfabetizada e mais tarde voltar a falar
um pouquinho sobre ela
ela está na nossa escola essa escola que
tem inspiração em regeane ilha e esta
criança tem uma grande influência na
coluna na comunidade
essa escola da mariana
um dos aspectos principais dentro dessa
abordagem é o incentivo ao espírito
científico pela carinha da criança vocês
conseguem observar o encantamento que
essa criança tem ao fazer uma descoberta
a perceber algo de novo naquele objeto
que está sendo investigado
existe toda uma compreensão do que
acontece na natureza dos sentidos que
nós temos e pelos quais a aprendizagem
vai passando
esse é o mesmo projeto que a gente
estava vendo antes que a criança estava
observando o crescimento de uma lagarta
transformação até
a esse ponto outro aspecto muito
importante a gente falar é a questão da
escuta ativa é dar a possibilidade da
criança se manifestar
vocês todos devem lembrar de uma
apresentadora que quando tinha uma
criança puxando assim a roupa dela falou
senta lá cláudia lembram disso
a gente não pode agir assim com a
criança a gente precisa não só escutar
usando a opção mas ter essa percepção
que a criança fala não só através da
linguagem oral
ela se expressa com seus gestos
ela se expressa no silêncio então em
todos os momentos essa escuta ativa é
desenvolvida as linguagens da criança
não são só essas linguagens com as quais
a gente está acostumada
ela também vai se manifestar através das
artes vai se manifestar também pelo
movimento a criança tem uma energia que
transborda ela não consegue ficar
sentadinha quietinha
a gente às vezes você fica quietinho não
fica quietinho se manifesta
deixa que essa energia acontecem você é
além disso nós podemos mostrar pra vocês
que a criança ela unindo essa percepção
dela de mundo daquilo que há certa ela
começa a produzir era um só recebe
saberes
ela produz os saberes que vêm de
diversas origens das famílias da
comunidade em que ela está da igreja que
ela frequenta e aí um dos aspectos mais
importantes dentro da abordagem é a
família
a nossa escola entende que a família
deve estar com a gente
a família não fica do portão para fora
as famílias da nossa escola elas estão
com a gente a todo momento elas estão na
reunião de pais
sim elas estão na reunião de pais
discutindo com os educadores aquilo que
é proposto de conteúdo de currículo
mas elas também estão
presente quando elas atuam junto às
crianças contando uma história quando
elas praticam com as crianças diferentes
atividades que a escola proporciona
então é essencial a presença da família
com a gente essa presença da família
também vai nos auxiliar no
desenvolvimento da autonomia
a criança se percebe confiante porque há
como os pais familiares estão dentro da
escola ela percebe que aquele um
ambiente seguro aquele ambiente é um
ambiente de referência não só para ela
mas para todos que a cercam e essa
autonomia é desenvolvida não só é é as
coisas corriqueiras do dia a dia buscar
uma agenda na capital chilena ela é
calçar o próprio sapato mas no
desenvolvimento do autoconhecimento na
compreensão das potencialidades que cada
criança tem das limitações que precisam
ser superadas do fortalecimento de tudo
o que essa criança tem a desenvolver
outro ponto a se falar é que esse
desenvolvimento da criança essa
autonomia o autoconhecimento ele não se
dá apenas no aspecto cognitivo ou seja
do conteúdo que se aprende mas no motor
o que eu consigo realizar o que eu posso
me esforçar mais para alcançar e no
efetivo
as crianças vão criando vínculos laços
que permitem que elas reconheçam nelas
mesmas aquilo que elas conseguem fazer
pela observação do outro e aquilo que
elas ainda podem melhorar sem precisar
de um educador falando você está errando
não é por aí
não faça desse jeito como já foi dito as
palavras têm uma uma força muito grande
na formação e principalmente na formação
da criança
se a gente usar palavras positivas e
possibilitar que essas crianças tenham
esse autoconhecimento
esse reconhecimento do que elas são
capazes de fazer
acredito que o caminho aí vai ser muito
melhor
é interessante a gente fala também que
vocês até agora acho que notaram não é
só dentro da sala de aula que a criança
aprende não é só sentar dia numa cadeira
fazendo uma atividade na mesinha que a
criança está se desenvolvendo o espaço
educa tudo aquilo que certa criança está
educando
então essas crianças preparam horta e
prepara desde o início
mexendo a terra a do bando colocando-a
mudou a semente acompanhando diariamente
o crescimento da quilo que é plantado e
aí a gente faz um paralelo né
ou seja aquilo que está sendo plantado
se desenvolve como vocês também se
desenvolvem
aquilo que a criança consegue é de
crescimento para uma plantinha também é
possível que a criança vai criando
vínculo com aquilo que a cerca
apreciação estética
será que a gente lembra de quando era
criança e ficava encantado ver nas
folhas das árvores balançando ouvindo o
canto de um pássaro observando os pingos
da chuva batendo na janela aqueles
desenhos que são feitos porque a gente
entendeu isso e pela correria do dia a
dia é porque a gente não tem mais tempo
para isso ou porque nós somos adultos
agora a gente não pode realizar isso
as crianças devem ser estimuladas nesse
aspecto apreciar tudo que a cerca
não estou falando de elementos da
natureza mas sim apreciar o que a
humanidade já produziu culturalmente na
música no teatro nas artes plásticas e
se essa apreciação estética também é
muito importante para o desenvolvimento
das crianças
na nossa escola mais do que por força da
lei mas principalmente porque nós
entendemos que as diferenças existem a
todo instante em qualquer lugar
nós promovemos a inclusão de crianças
não vou falar com deficiência porque
todos nós temos as nossas deficiências
mas crianças que têm necessidades
educacionais especiais crianças que
precisam de um olhar mais atento de uma
participação um pouco mais ativa de
todos que a cercam para poder se
desenvolver
então o universo de 80 crianças mais ou
menos da nossa educação infantil
nós temos crianças autistas com síndrome
de down com paralisia cerebral com baixa
visão e todas essas crianças são
acolhidas pelos seus colegas pelos
outros membros da comunidade escolar de
forma irrestrita a gente entende que
essas diferenças são capazes de
potencializar o desenvolvimento de todas
as crianças
indo um pouco mais além é importante
mencionar a questão da consciência
global
a gente entende que a criança tem noção
de causa e conseqüência
talvez não em grandes dimensões o que eu
faço aqui pode ter um efeito mundial mas
elas têm essa percepção de que o mundo
que é cerca é influenciado por elas e
elas são realmente é protagonistas desse
desenvolvimento
aí já colhendo os frutos da da horta que
eles plantaram uma atividade que eles
desenvolveram dentro de um mapa múndi
para ter essa percepção de que tudo se
conecta tudo está relacionado
as coisas não são tão distante
parecem ser dando continuidade eu vou
fazer vou tentar fazer pra vocês
lembrando de lloris malagutti que eu
falei lá no início é ele escreveu ele
não foi um teórico de produção é extensa
mas ele escreveu um poema que eu acho
importante ler pra vocês
eles se chamam ao contrário as 100
existem
a criança é feita de serra
as crianças têm em mãos sem pensamentos
sem modos de pensar de jogar de falar
sempre sem modos de escutar as
maravilhas de amar sem alegrias para
cantar e compreender sem mundos para
descobrir sem mundos para inventar sem
mundos para sonhar
a criança tem sem linguagem depois 100
cem 100 mas roubaram de 99
a escola ea cultura separá lo ea cabeça
do corpo dizem-lhe para pensar sem as
mãos para fazer sem a cabeça para
escutar e não falar para compreender sem
alegrias para maravilhar se apenas na
páscoa e no natal disse ele para
descobrir o mundo que já existe e de 100
roubaram-lhe 99 dizem que o jô e o
trabalho a realidade ea fantasia ciência
imaginação o céu ea terra a razão e os
sonhos são coisas que não estão juntas
dislike as 100 não existem
a criança diz ao contrário a 100 existem
voltar na mariana
a mariana é uma criança que hoje tem
sete anos e que foi capaz quando tinha
apenas 4 anos de transformar a realidade
que ela vivia na escola ela escutar
a professora sobre a importância de
separar aqueles itens que são
descartáveis
o lixo para reciclagem e fazer isso
sozinha
lavava os potinhos jogava no lixo que
ela determinava e de tanto insistir com
a família a família se transformou e
começou a fazer a coleta seletiva
a mariana é a minha filha ea mariana
transformou a minha vida assim como a
mariana outras crianças também podem
fazer isso
é só dá oportunidade para que isso
aconteça obrigada